[Music]
hi everyone welcome to the session on
the new multi camera API
my name is Veneto D and I'm the product
manager on the camera platform just a
quick reminder after this talk please
step outside to the sandbox area if
you'd like to ask us more questions
before we talk about the new API let me
give a quick update on the state of
camera historically most camera apps
focus on the native camera app that
ships with the device it turns out
however that more than twice the amount
of camera usage occurs on the apps that
you build and it's extremely important
that you support the new features that
are available in the new Android API s
when we speak to a lot of developers
what we find is that the number one
question is the state of camera2 api and
where we're going to be going forward
we've been working very hard and
starting with Android P what you'll find
is almost all new devices will support
camera two and he'll three what this
means is when you look at the camera
characteristics you'll find that the
device will advertise itself as either
camera 2 limited which is similar to a
point-and-shoot a camera 2 full which
offers advanced capabilities like for
frame control and level 3 which enables
y UV reprocessing in RAW in addition
we've been working with several OEMs or
manufacturers to open up new api's at
launch so we're excited this year that
both the Google pixel 3 and the hallway
made 20 series support the new multi
camera API now let me step back and say
why this new API is so important prior
to Android P as developers you only get
access to one of the physical sensors
where the native camera app gets access
to the full hardware capability but
starting with P you'll get the same
access as the native camera app this
includes all the physical sensors
plus the logical camera and the logical
camera is a abstraction of all the
physical sensors that allows you to
easily take advantage of the hardware
there are several new use cases and
possibilities with the new multi camera
API today
Oscar is going to talk about optical
zoom and Emily is going to cover bouquet
thank you very much
Oscars up next hi everyone my name is
Oscar I work in the developer relations
team and we're gonna start off with a
live demo what could go wrong so here I
have a mate 20 phone we are implementing
multi camera zoom what we're doing here
is we are swapping at the UI layer the
two camera streams I'm not doing any
kind of digital zoom or cropping I'm
simply swapping the streams as you can
see it's almost instantaneous
there's no teardown and bring up on the
camera session it's just a single
session and I'm swapping the two camera
streams the idea is that as I said
single camera session two streams and
we're gonna swap between the streams and
we're gonna show you how this was built
the key component though is that we had
the same code running on both devices as
many camera developers now it is quite a
feat to have the same code running
across such different devices especially
for something as tied to the hardware as
it is multi camera so first let's talk
about how we can use multiple camera
streams simultaneously the basic
currenty provided by the framework in
the multi camera API is that you can use
at least two physical camera streams at
the same time recall the guaranteed
stream configurations for single camera
devices it is a set of rules based on
hardware level target type and target
size if we use the multi camera API as
correctly we can get an exception to
these rules less illustrate this with an
example we have a single
Yub stream of maximum size as per the
previous table devices with
limited Harvard level we'll be able to
use a single stream with a configuration
if we use the multi-camera api's we can
actually use two streams of equivalent
configuration from the underlying
physical cameras let's walk through what
we need to do to implement the app that
we just demoed earlier we broke it down
to five steps are you ready step number
one find the physical cameras we will
start identifying pairs of physical
cameras that can be opened
simultaneously using the camera
characters the subject we look for the
other test capabilities and if logical
multi camera is one of them we know this
device is a logical camera another we
phonological camera we store it will
need the ID for later we'll see and we
get the physical cameras associated with
it then we can move on to the next step
here's a visualization of what we just
described we take that logical camera ad
and with the characteristics we call get
physical camera IDs and now we retrieve
the physical cameras associated with a
logical camera group onto the next step
open logical camera the second step is
nothing new we open the camera recall
the logical camera ad we saved earlier
that is the only one we use to pass to
the camera manager so to reiterate we
only open the logical camera the state
callback with trigger when the device is
ready we have now opened a logical
camera in the next step we'll create the
upper configuration objects they will be
used to create the camera session for
each desired output target we may have a
physical camera ad from the list we
phone earlier if we want to retrieve
frames from a specific Harvard camera
let's go into more details
we create the upper configuration object
using our desire output target and if we
want to associate that up with a
specific specific physical camera then
we pass the ad in the set physical
camera IV API if we want to use a
logical camera we can simply skip this
step we may also have a combination of
both so at the end of the day we have a
list of upper configurations some of
which may be associated with physical
cameras some of which what your camera
the goal is to put all the
configurations into a single session
configuration as we just explained each
auto configuration has an Associated
output target and optionally a physical
camera ad now we create the capture
session how do we create the capture
session using the new session
configuration object we start off with
our list of applicants figurations that
we just created with that we instantiate
assessing configuration which includes
the capture session call back from that
call back we're going to get an instance
of the created camera session we take
that system configuration object and the
camera device which we got from a step
number two when we open logical camera
and we send the framework the request to
create a new session with our desired
configuration the callback provided in
the session configuration object will be
triggered now and then we'll have our
camera set and ready to be used
last step come to requests once that has
happened we can start getting frames out
of the cameras for example if you want
to capture a frame from two physical
camera simultaneously we take the
session we created earlier and a pair of
output targets in this particular case
each target will be associated with a
specific camera ID we create the capture
request that we normally do in this case
using template preview
we attach the
Tigers to it again like we normally bill
and now we dispatch the capture request
nothing different here except in this
case the output surfaces will receive
image data from each of the SOC a
physical cameras and the capture request
call that will trigger only once so
again it's just like any capture request
the big difference is that the
completion callback will give me back to
start exposure time stamps instead of
just a single value from normal capture
requests so to recap this is how
implement our optical zoom demo we found
a physical cameras we open the logical
camera that is part of that group we
create the up to auto configurations we
learnt a list we create our capture
session and then we dispatcher capture
requests one more topic I'm going to
touch on is lens distortion a classical
example of lens distortion is the
fisheye lens this is not a real example
it is here for illustration purposes
only all lenses have some amount of
distortion for logical cameras you can
assume that that distortion will be
minimal for the most part will be
corrected by the drivers however for
physical cameras distortion can be
pretty significant the physical lens
distortion is described in a set of
radial and tangential coefficients the
coefficients can be queried using the
lens distortion camera characteristic
scheme the documentation has a lot more
details if you're interested the good
news is that there is a way to create
distortion without doing a bunch of math
we can simply set the distortion
correction mode on our capture requests
means that no distortion is applied we
may need to use this if you want to do
things like friend synchronization Emily
will touch on that later fast means that
the best possible correction is applied
while meeting the advertised frame rate
if no fast correction is possible this
may be the same as off high quality
means that distortion will be corrected
as much as the less allows
potentially at the cost of frame rate if
we don't specify a correction mode it
will be there fast or high-quality it is
going to be after the implementation
details which is the default you as a
developer can query to see which one was
applied to your capture request let's
see a code snippet demonstrating how
this lens distortion is set to high
quality which is probably what we want
for a still image capture
assuming we already started our camera
session we instantiate the capture
request builder using our desired
template in this case as I said image
capture then we use the camera
characteristics to determine if high
quality distortion correction mode is
available now that we know that we have
high quality correction for the
distortion we set it on the capture
request and we do what we always do
dispatch the capture request
for more sample code and technical
details take a look at our blog post we
covered this and some more we published
earlier this week and now I'll hand it
over to Emily thanks Oscar
my name is Emily Roberts I'm a partner
developer advocate and I'm going to show
you a cool demo that uses some of these
multi camera API is to do a bouquet
effect on the pixel 3 so we actually
have three well two demos 22.5 demos the
first one is a single cam demo there's
no multi camera at all
but I wanted to sort of show the
mechanisms for creating the bouquet
effect then when we get into the dual
cam demo you'll see exactly you know we
can focus on the multi camera aspects
and not worry so much about the bouquet
effect itself and it's gonna be
published soon open source so don't
worry about scribbling down too much
code so can we go to this phone demo
oops excuse me okie dokie so we have I
didn't set this up properly okay let's
do the single cam bouquet effect taking
a selfie here and I think you can see on
the screen it's finding my face it's
cutting it out let me bump up the final
result and it's kind of pasting the
portrait mode in there this is kind of a
rough cut portrait mode and I do have an
optimization on this let's see how that
goes I'll show you the output steps here
so it's trying to do a better job of
finding the foreground it didn't do too
bad it's generating the foreground image
the background which is just monochrome
then blurred a little bit and come on up
don't let us down pacing on the final
result so that's not too bad for a
single cam let's try the dual cam demo
and with these stage lights I'm not sure
come on
hey not too bad we're doing good so you
can see a depth map being created in the
bottom left hand corner that's detecting
me in the foreground and then the rest
y'all a little bit faded out you can see
the closer folks are a gray and then
black goes right to the back you can
also see the lights wreaking some havoc
let me show you the final result
obviously there's a few optimizations
that can happen but it's working pretty
well so again this is using the two
front cameras on the pixel - you can see
the two streams going at once
oops we'll just connect back up no
anyway both streams at once the wide
angle lens in the normal angle lens
going at the same time can we head back
to the slides please so let's talk about
how we do that well there we are anyway
so we had the normal camera and the wide
angle lens running at the same time
again we're gonna publish this on
probably github open source so you can
dig into it help us optimize it make it
even better so the first case the single
cam let's look at that quickly the
floating head bouquet effect I call it
we're gonna take a photo with face
detect we're gonna make two copies so we
have background foreground do some sort
of fancy background effects and then
paste that floating head back where it
belongs face detect is built into the
camera to API it's quite easy in code to
implement first thing we want to do is
check the camera characteristics to see
if your camera device supports face
detect if it does you find the mode you
want there is off and then simple and
full depending on your camera device
then when we make our camera capture
request we just include that in the
request when we get our results you can
see if the mode was set if you found any
faces and in this example I just search
for the first face that defines is the
one I used we could imagine expanding
this to have multiple faces just a known
face detect really grabs the really the
face so I just bump those bounds out a
little bit so it's more of a head
chopped off that sounds bad I had being
pasted onto the background let's talk
about the fun background effects so you
can do what you want here I did a couple
things first
using renderscript we just did a blur on
the background and because it's a multi
camera talk some cameras have a manual
zoom so you keep you're working with
multicam you could do the background
with another camera in zoom it way out
of focus you could actually do an
optical blur which would be kind of cool
and also save you that software step in
this demo we also did a custom software
sepia effect using render script but if
you're using multicam again lots of
cameras have built-in effects like
monochrome in sepia that you can query
and include in your capture request as
well if you haven't used render script
before it looks something like this and
for our blur effect we care most about
the three middle lines and it's a built
in script intrinsic blur it's pretty
handy and it basically works outside the
box out of the box in this case it
blurred outside of the box because the
box it's not blurry this is a custom
render script script for the sepia
effect you can see in those first three
lines basically we're taking the input
red green and blue channels kind of
muting the colors making them a bit
yellow and sending those to the output
channels okey-dokey so we've got the
background it's got this cool bouquet
effect on it what do we do with the
foreground from face detect we've got
the face cut out and we just apply a
bordered off with a linear gradient to
make the edges a bit softer so when we
paste it on it's not that harsh line and
tada paste it on and things look pretty
good there's a couple of optimizations
one you saw which is with the grab cut
algorithm this is built into open CV the
open computer vision library that we're
using for the depth map demo later on
basically I found the face and then I
chose a rectangle a bit larger to try to
guess where the body might be and then
grab cut does its best like the magic
wand tool in your favorite photo editor
to shrink down that foreground to the
actual foreground bounds we could also
as I mention add in multiple faces now
the moment you've all been waiting for
let's talk about dual cam bouquet with
the depth map we're going to use two
cameras simultaneously and we're gonna
create a depth map which is the hard
part which I highlighted that in bold
but then we go ahead and use the same
mechanism we already talked about okie
dokie how does this work first of all
the double capture so this on the left
is this me hanging out with my pets at
home the left is the normal camera in
the pixel three front cameras and the
right is the wide-angle shot to do that
just as Oscar walk through we set out
multiple output configurations so for
each lens we set up here we have the
preview surface as well as an image
reader for the normal lens we use set
physical camera ID to the normal lens
and we do the same thing for the
wide-angle lens so we end up with four
output configurations we're putting into
our configuration from then from there
it's just a matter of choosing our
output targets for the capture in this
case we want those photos so we can
operate on them so we say we want the
image reader from the normal lens and
the wide-angle lens okay so we have our
images now we have to do a bunch of math
and some magic and make that bouquet
effect happen I want to give a brief
introduction to stereo vision before we
get into all the code but I have to say
looking at these slides working on these
slides I got a little bit bored I like
geometry but you know it's a lot of
letters and I started asking myself what
does P stand for anyway obviously it's a
pile of chocolate P stands for a pile of
chocolate and this is what we're going
to be focusing on for the rest of this
demo and you know camera one is a little
bit boring camera two so s here we're
gonna replace with a shark this is my
friend pepper the shark and H is hippo
so these are our helpers that are going
to help us talk about stereo vision so
left camera normal lens is pepper of the
shark wide-angle lens is Susie Lou the
couch hippopotamus and they're both
zeroing in on that
big pile of chocolate and already it's a
lot more fun I hope you agree
so those skewed rectangles there that's
the 2d surface that's like the image
that the cameras are going to capture in
other words the 2d representation of
that real live 3d object we have let's
take a look at what that looks like the
shark eye view is right in there on the
Allman's sea salt and dark chocolate
whereas the hippocampus tin on the
raspberry crunch so they're both seeing
the same 3d object but they have this 2d
representation and what we really want
to do is take their separate views and
be able to combine them so we get a
little bit more information than that 2d
view and be able to create a great depth
map so we have the again the normal view
the wide-angle view well in this case
they're both normal at the left hand the
right hand overlay on each other you get
that kind of 3d ruler effect from
elementary school that I hope you got to
enjoy as a child and from there we can
create a depth map which allows you to
do really cool things like awesome
bouquet effects as well as know how far
away the chocolate is so you can reach
out and grab it
obviously okey dokey so those two
cameras those two pictures are at a
different orientation from each other
and they're separated in space so we
need to get those on top of each other
this is what we call the camera
extrinsic so two cameras relate to each
other so we need to rotate and translate
each of those images so they appear on
top of each other normally we say that
we normally give the rotation and
translation parameters for a camera in
relation to world so instead of camera
one to world we'll have shark two world
and hippo two world but when we're doing
stereo vision what we really need to
worry about is shark two hippo so how
are these two cameras related to each
other like a good engineer all I know is
I have to switch hippo to world to be
world two hippo and now I have this
pathway from shark to world two hippo I
hope that was a fun introduction to the
math which you can read all about on
Wikipedia and looks something like this
to get the rotation matrix we gonna
inverse the rotation matrix for camera
two and cross multiply it with camera
one
and for translation it's something like
this take the inner product and subtract
you can read all about on Wikipedia or
other sources so one thing I want to
just point out if you're working on this
yourself is the translation matrix for a
pixel tree from the normal camera to the
wide camera this is what I got out what
do you notice about it the 9 millimeter
separation between the cameras looks
just about right if you look at the
phone you know there's a good what's the
American a good anyway there's a good 9
millimeters between those cameras that
makes perfect sense but what I didn't
notice in which cost me about a week of
time is that it's in the y-coordinate so
the cameras are on top of each other and
so while I'm working with this phone
looking at the two cameras beside each
other I just assumed that they were
obviously horizontally displaced no big
deal except that the depth map function
that I'm using assumes that they're
gonna be beside each other it zooms
horizontal displacement so you just have
good because I didn't say the important
part camera sensors are often optimized
for landscape which makes sense if you
do it wrong your depth maps don't work
you pull your hair out you have a great
week like I did anyway just a note if
you're implementing this so we have the
camera extrinsic s-- how we get the
pictures from the cameras on top of each
other how they relate to each other
camera intrinsics are properties of the
cameras themselves so we know we have a
normal lens and a wide-angle lens and
they have different properties so
there's two things one is the camera
characteristics this is things like the
focal length the principal axis and if
that access is skewed for some reason
this appears often in the 3 by 3 matrix
and distortion the wide-angle lens and
any wide angle lens near the edges
especially you're going to get a little
bit of distortion going on that we need
to consider as we're mapping the two
images to each other another note so
we're gonna use the intrinsic distortion
properties of the lens to undistorted
image but as Oscar told us by default
the camera under source image for us so
we're going to undistorted and then re
undistorted which means we're actually
going to distort it which is bad news so
we actually need to turn off the
distortion
correction if you want to do to depth
maps that's easy enough with the our
camera request we just make sure that
distortion mode is off okie dokie so
here's the four things rotation
translation the camera characteristics
matrix and the lens Distortion
how do you get these properties it's
pretty easy you just take an entire
afternoon printout a checkerboard sheet
or is anyone in this room done this
before
it's called camera yeah it's fun right
it's great camera calibration take a
whole series of shots with both the
cameras you run a bunch of algorithms
you figure out these four camera
characteristics and from then you can go
ahead and start making depth maps from
the cameras you can tell from my
cheerful face it's not actually that fun
don't do it it's no good luckily in the
camera to multi camera api's we have
these great fields rotation translation
calibration and distortion so you can
get it straight out of the API which is
wonderful I'm going to just tell you a
few notes if you're implementing these
yourself so the camera characteristics
the focal length and the access
information comes in five parameters
this is in the Android documentation but
to create that 3x3 matrix you just have
to follow the documentation and plug in
the numbers another thing that might
throw you off is the distortion
coefficients again are five values but
the opencv library uses them in a
different order than the values to get
out of the API so you just need to know
that it goes 0 1 3 4 - the good news is
if you if use them in the 0 1 2 3 4
order when you undistorted as they look
like they've been in a whirlpool so
you're sure something's wrong with those
2 coefficients anyway so once we have
all those parameters we can go ahead and
start preparing our images to do a depth
map comparison this is me and my kitchen
I don't know if you can see from there
but if you look at the ceiling you'll
notice there's kind of a curve going
down we don't live in the funhouse
it's the distortion effects we're
talking about with the wide-angle lens
with distortion correction off as well
when you're comparing two images the
straight lines while in the curved lines
need to line up in each of the images
when you're making it up
ma'am we call that rectifying and we use
the camera characteristics to do that
that's just showing the the Ben roof all
of these functions are in the opencv
library the open computer vision library
the first one is stereo rectified this
gets a set of parameters we can use to
perform these calculations so we pass in
the coal sorry the values we got from
the API the camera matrix the distortion
coefficients the rotation and
translation that we calculated before we
get these parameters out and we call
undistorted IMAP which creates a map
telling us how we can take two images
from these two different cameras and map
them onto each other and the remap
function does just this so let's see
what that gives us here is on the left
again from the normal cam front cam of
the pixel 3 and the wide-angle lens from
the pixel 3 you can see they look pretty
good
the shark lines are lined up the crop is
about right you know the wide angle has
a lot more crop region that's all lined
up the roof lines the door lines are
straight there's no wacky Distortion and
actually I'd say from where you're
sitting you probably have to look
closely to notice that the left-hand
picture is a little bit closer to the
left-hand side of the frame so they're
actually offset by a little bit which is
just about what you'd expect if you had
two cameras 9 millimeters apart so we
got the images we've undistorted we
rectified them or we're very close to
creating the depth maps all we have to
do is call the depth map function we use
stereo BM or stereo SG BM one has a few
more parameters than the other and when
you get to play with the open source
demo you can see how these parameters
work and play around with it optimize
them commit your changes help make that
better and we call compute and make this
depth map and when you do that you'll
get an amazing photo something like this
actually sometimes it looks a lot better
than that but anyway this isn't quite
what we want to work with what we really
want to do is filter that in this case
using a weighted least squares filter
which smooth that out and gives us a
little bit more useful depth map
so the darker pixels as we saw in the
demo or the ones farther back the whiter
pixels are the closer ones and it's a
little probably a little hard to see you
can see the Sharks note in the hippos
known are a little bit grayed out so it
it's actually working to some extent
there this is how we call the filter
it's also including the opencv libraries
in the contributor modules it's all open
source and it's really cool when you get
a depth map that is perfect you it's
exhilarating okay here we have our def
to map what do we do with it
so we can just apply this depth map as a
mask on top of it and the black areas we
want to fade out and we want to
highlight the foreground that's pretty
easy to do with a porter def and the
result is something like this so indeed
the foreground is more present and then
the background is faded out personally I
have high standards I see like a
translucent floating shark over my
shoulder my face is a little bit greyed
out my eyeballs missing so I'm gonna put
another big red X through this and say
not quite good enough it's a good start
but what we really want is a depth map
more like this so we're going to put a
hard threshold on the depth map and
decide foreground background that's it
in other apps you may want to do
something similar but maybe not such a
harsh distinction it could be a smoother
curve to do that we can use the opencv
function threshold we give it some
cutoff value for the app it's somewhere
around 80 to 140 out of 255 and that's
just that limit where something is
considered foreground or background I
wanted to note this in case you're
implementing any of this when we applied
the mask like I showed you actually need
to turn those black pixels to
transparent pixels so this function just
goes through and converts all the black
ones to transparency and here we go
we're almost there so I want to know one
thing on this slide the middle picture
you can see my eye is a bit blacked out
just
remember that for three more slides or
so so we have our initial picture we've
got our depth map we do this hard
threshold on it and we can again create
our background just like we did in the
first demo and blur it out mono
monochrome it and cut out that
foreground we have all the pieces we
need to paste it on and this is our
amazing final portrait shot which it's
pretty good I'm proud of it so let's
talk about an optimization I remember
that eyeball thing I was talking about
so anything kind of gleaming and shiny
can get messed up in this current
iteration of the application or bright
lights can throw off the depth map
generation and so I did one optimization
which was we have the face detect region
I'm pretty sure I want the face in the
foreground so I just used it in hard cut
it in and said anything on the face is
going to be in the foreground so that
protected like my teeth and my eye from
the that masking out effect I don't know
if you noticed can I go back my fuzzy
red hair and the red couch there we go
they kind of blend in and so I'm
thinking we could use grab cut possibly
to do a little bit better job of
figuring out exactly what's in the
foreground so thanks a lot we really
hope that this gave you a bit of a deep
dive into using camera two and the multi
camera API is giving you some exciting
creative ideas we really want to hear
your ideas and we really want to see
them in your apps and we also want to
know what features you're looking for we
think they're great and we want to keep
pushing the camera ecosystem forward and
doing more and more stuff really
ecosystem wide thanks so much again and
please do come to the sandbox camera
sandbox if you want to ask us any
questions you want any follow-ups you
want to try this app and see if it works
and look for it soon open-source thanks
a lot
[Music]